Traductor: Laura Heredia Abolafio
Revisor: Adelina Bordea
Magdalena y María jugaban
sobre un tablero vacío
y lo hacían con una sola pieza.
La tengo aquí.
La pieza del caballo.
Les habíamos pedido que intentaran
resolver el problema de Euler.
El problema del salto del caballo,
que es aquel que nos obliga mover
la pieza por todas las casillas, las 64,
sin pisar dos veces la misma casilla.
Parece fácil, pero no lo es.
Esa mañana, para amenizar
un poco la dinámica
les habíamos repartido
a Madalena y a María,
que jugaban en pareja,
y al resto de parejas,
les habíamos repartido unos cuencos
con unos garbanzos.
Y les habíamos pedido que pusieran esas
legumbres en cada una de las casillas.
Cuando el caballo se quedaba
sin casilla libre,
la pareja se retiraba y esperaba al resto.
Magdalena y María estaban muy nerviosas.
Su corcel había sido algo así
como Pulgarcito, ¿no?
Y ya barruntaban ellas
qué iba a ser
de toda esa hilera de tableros,
el suyo el más parecido
a una huerta fértil de leguminosas.
Es decir, que habría muchos garbanzos.
Y efectivamente, de hecho
en los recuentos fueron
las justas ganadoras,
con 53 saltos de caballo.
Aplausos, júbilos, abrazos.
Felicidad sincera.
Algunos estaréis diciendo:
«Bueno, pero si es un simple juego».
Sí, es un simple juego,
pero lo extraordinario de esta historia
es que Magdalena tiene cerca de 80 años,
si no los tiene ya,
y María no sabe leer y no sabe escribir.
Ellas se fueron a su casa
felices, radiantes,
con la energía catapultada a esos niveles
donde solo sale la autoestima,
el afán de logro.
Porque se habían dado cuenta
de que eran capaces de tomar decisiones,
de planificar.
Lo que subyace
de esta entrañable historia,
aún recuerdan que son las ganadoras.
Casi, casi resuelven el problema de Euler.
Se quedaron a diez saltitos, ¿eh?
Aún lo recuerdan.
Pues lo interesantísimo y la pregunta
que subyace de esta entrañable historia
no es otra que la toma de decisiones.
¿Cómo podemos tomar decisiones?
¿Cómo podemos tomar mejores decisiones?
¿Qué elementos entran en juego?
Nunca mejor dicho.
Paul Slovic fue un psicólogo cognitivo
que tras muchos estudios y experimentos
nos dijo algo muy interesante.
Nos dijo que, para la toma de decisiones,
a veces, tomamos más en cuenta
nuestras emociones que
nuestros juicios y reflexiones.
Es decir, que damos respuestas
a cómo me siento,
y no tanto a cómo pienso o a qué pienso.
Y esto en el juego del ajedrez también
se observa y de una forma muy clara.
Ya sé qué estáis pensando.
«Pero el juego del ajedrez no era
algo reflexivo, analítico...».
Bueno, sí, pero no.
Porque quien haya jugado al ajedrez,
sabe la tremenda y terrible tensión
que uno tiene cuando ve un reloj que
se acaba implacable y te obliga a mover.
Cuántas veces en la vida, sabemos
que tenemos el turno,
pero no nos atrevemos a mover y vamos
procastinándolo, vamos dejándolo, vamos...
«Ya se resolverá», ¿no?
En el ajedrez esto no es posible.
O mueves, o mueves.
Y si no, pierdes.
Ahí hay una presión brutal.
Tenemos un sentimiento tal
que a veces movemos
para sentir alivio. «Uf, ya está».
La jugada a lo mejor
nos lleva a la derrota,
pero nosotros nos sentimos bien.
Y por eso se ve tan claramente
esto que nos decía Slovic.
En realidad, incluso cuando
nos enfrentamos a un rival
que pensamos que es superior a nosotros,
esta tensión sube mucho más.
Y cualquier distracción
también puede influir poderosamente
en la toma de decisiones.
Cuentan que Lasker, que fue un filósofo,
matemático y, en sus ratos libres
se hizo campeón del mundo de ajedrez,
pues cuentan que Lasker
jugaba una partida con Nimzowitch,
otro gran teórico
de la historia del noble juego,
y Lasker era un fumador empedernido.
Estaba todo el día fumando habanos.
Y Nimzowitch lo detestaba,
no quería ni oler el tabaco.
Le pidió a Lasker que, por favor,
durante la partida no fumara.
Lasker, amablemente le dijo:
«No te preocupes, que no voy a fumar».
Pero en lo que los aficionados llamamos
el medio juego, Lasker se sacó su puro.
Algunos cuentan que
se lo pasaba por la boca,
otros que jugueteaba con él
entre los dedos,
y claro, esto a Nimzowitch le irritaba.
Valga la broma fácil,
le sacaba de sus casillas.
Y se lo hizo ver a Lasker:
«Oye, habías dicho que no ibas a fumar».
«No estoy fumando.
Además, usted, maestro Nimzowitch»,
imagino que le diría en ese tono,
«debería saber que la amenaza
es más fuerte que su ejecución».
¡Toma ya! Y es cierto,
a veces, nos inventamos jaques,
amenazas que no son tan reales.
Es decir, no es tan fácil elegir
una buena decisión.
No es tan fácil el proceso, ¿verdad?
Es bastante confuso.
Porque con esta influencia emocional
que dice Slovic
con esta presión implacable del tiempo
uf, qué difícil, ¿no?
Bueno, pues el ajedrez te enseña a algo,
es una herramienta, que te enseña
una destreza fundamental
que es el reconocimiento de patrones.
El ajedrez te enseña
no solo a reconocerlos,
sino incluso a construir patrones.
Patrones, definamos, como
una serie de elementos,
de constantes variables
que se repiten, que son identificables
y que son recurrentes,
sabemos identificarlos.
En una partida de ajedrez,
en una posición determinada,
si sabemos identificar
que una dama y un alfil
se han puesto de acuerdo
para operar por una misma diagonal,
eso nos da confianza.
Hemos reconocido un patrón y decimos:
«Qué bien, no voy tan mal».
Empezamos a soltar un poco
de la emoción a la que se refería Slovic
a esta tensión terrible
de la que hablamos.
Porque sabemos que esa batería,
que los chicos llaman cuando empiezan
a jugar al ajedrez "el trenecito",
a veces nos lleva, como en el ejemplo,
a una posición hasta ganadora.
No siempre, pero bueno.
Más o menos, ¿no?
La suerte es que
practicando con frecuencia,
no vale jugar una partida,
pero si lo practicamos con frecuencia,
la suerte es que el ajedrez nos enseña,
nos entrena, a identificar patrones,
porque en la vida también existen
patrones, patrones sociales
Imaginémonos que estamos de visita
en cualquier otro país
visitando otras costumbres,
culturas, destinos, lugares.
No reconocemos patrones, algunos sí,
pero cuando llegamos al aeropuerto,
todo nos suena familiar.
Parece que ya hemos vuelto a Málaga.
Los paneles de información,
las puertas de embarque.
Esto ya me lo conozco, ¿verdad?
Es como casi una partida de ajedrez
por la que ya has pasado.
Esto me suena.
La buena noticia es que todas
y todos los que estamos aquí
somos unos magníficos
buscadores de patrones.
Lo hacemos por instinto,
por naturaleza.
Hemos venido a ello,
pero también podemos entrenarlo
y el milenario juego nos enseña.
Hagámosle caso, juguemos con él
porque vamos a ser
magníficos, como digo,
pero además vamos a poder
incluso crearlos.
¿No os ha pasado ninguna vez,
supongo que sí, que cuando
os habéis acercado
a un grupo de amigos, de repente,
notáis que cambian la conversación,
las miradas, las risas...
y tú dices: «Estaban hablando de mí».
(Risas) ¿A qué sí? (Risas)
Esto es un patrón social,
por eso digo que somos muy buenos en ello.
Bueno pues, somos tan magníficos que
entendemos y comprendemos la realidad
gracias a este tipo de asideros,
de garantía, de confianza
que nos otorgan los patrones.
El ajedrez te enseña a ello.
Un patrón ajedrecístico muy útil
para nuestra vida diaria
es precisamente el que se inspira
en la enseñanza para la comprensión.
Es una mirada educativa,
un tipo de aprendizaje
que emana del Proyecto Zero
de la Universidad de Harvard,
con David Perkins a la cabeza
y podemos verlo en un tablero de ajedrez.
El tipo de pensamiento que defiende
la enseñanza para la comprensión
nivela y escalona en tres,
observar, pensar y preguntarse,
lo que deberíamos hacer.
En una partida, en otra posición
que podemos ver,
da igual que no sepáis de ajedrez, yo creo
que se va a entender perfectamente,
porque, ¿qué observo? Un tablero de
ajedrez y unas piezas, ya está, ¿verdad?
Todo el mundo lo sabe.
¿Qué pienso sobre ello?
Pienso que, aunque no sepa mucho,
las blancas tienen menos piezas
y no parece que vayan muy bien, ¿no?
¿Y qué me pregunto sobre ello?
Me pregunto quién es
el poseedor del turno.
¿A quién le toca mover?
Porque si somos blancas,
podemos tomar la decisión de rendirnos
ante la clara desventaja.
Tenemos poquitas piezas, ¿verdad?
Pero si nos toca mover, quizás podamos ver
que con una sola jugada
hemos conseguido ganar la partida.
Estas rutinas de pensamiento
son tan importantes en la vida
porque nos ayudan a regar
una construcción mental
de un árbol de decisiones,
a tener ramificaciones,
a tener opciones.
Podemos mejorar nuestra toma de decisiones
si no movemos la primera que
se nos pasa por la cabeza.
Si tenemos un árbol a donde agarrarnos,
por lo menos mirar otras perspectivas.
Lasker, se acuerdan, ¿no?, el del puro.
Lasker nos dejó escrita una frase
que para mí es un consejo de vida.
Lasker dijo:
«Cuando veas una buena jugada,
trata de encontrar otra mejor».
Siguiendo el consejo de Lasker,
me atrevo incluso a mirar un tablero
como un espejo de la realidad, como,
si me lo permitís, como una obra de arte
donde hay escondidas muchas informaciones
que a simple vista no vemos.
Me gusta verlo como le pasó
a un escritor, dramaturgo, novelista,
llamado Theophile Gautier, que en 1846
visitó el Museo del Prado
con la única intención de contemplar
Las Meninas de Velázquez.
Gautier se puso delante del lienzo,
observó Las Meninas,
pensó sobre Las Meninas,
y tras un largo silencio,
preguntó en voz alta:
«Pero ¿dónde está el cuadro?».
Y claro, yo me lo imagino pensando
con ese paso atrás del pintor
que da Velázquez en el cuadro.
Me lo imagino
con esa pausa que te da
el juego del ajedrez
para no caer en el chantaje del tiempo.
En esta urgencia 3.0
en la que todos estamos.
Pero me imagino a Gautier
dando ese paso atrás,
tomando perspectiva,
encontrando una jugada en la casilla H8,
encontrando un secreto donde solo veía
a una infanta Margarita,
pero luego pensando
en el atrevimiento de Diego Velázquez,
que de repente se mete en el cuadro
que nos mira como espectadores,
que no sabemos si está pintando
al rey Felipe IV con Mariana de Austria
que de repente se proyecta al fondo,
como una especie de espejo,
que quizás no es un espejo, que quizás
es el tercer cuadro del cuadro... ¡Buah!
Me imagino a Gautier haciendo
este tipo de disquisiciones,
incluso no sé, pensaría que el enano bufón
de la corte italiana, aquel de allá,
que parece que está jugando o pegando
una patada a un mastín,
Nicolasito Pertusato, incluyo
que también le llamó la atención.
Por eso reivindico con la historia
de Gautier, que demos un paso atrás,
que podamos ganar perspectiva,
que ganemos compresión.
Porque cuando jugamos al ajedrez,
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
resolver problemas y tomar decisiones.
Justo lo que hacemos todos los días
de nuestras vidas. Justo.
Cuando vemos una jugada que nos lleva
al jaque mate, a la victoria,
en realidad, estamos pisando el terreno
de la creatividad, del pensamiento lateral
y cuando nos anticipamos
a la jugada del otro,
no sabéis la felicidad que da.
Incluso hay cruces de miradas.
«te la he adivinado, ¿ahora qué?».
¿Verdad? El que ha jugado, lo sabe.
Cuando estamos pensando en qué vamos
a hacer ahora, pero también
en qué vamos a hacer a largo plazo,
en un pensamiento más estratégico,
estamos trabajando en el enfoque dual,
importantísimo en nuestras vidas,
que es la táctica y estrategia,
como diría Benedetti.
Pero por encima de cualquier
otra habilidad o destreza cognitiva
o asociativa, por encima de
cualquier otra destreza, surge con fuerza
el reconocimiento de los propios errores.
El ajedrez te enseña a ser responsable,
no vale el terreno embarrado, el árbitro,
no valen excusas.
No hay cuartada posible.
Cada uno de hace responsable de lo que
ha movido en el tablero.
Que importante sería transferir
esa habilidad a nuestro día a día ¿verdad?
Todo este tipo de reflexiones
que nos enseñan que cada vez
que movemos una pieza en el tablero,
estamos modificando
por completo la posición
así como cada vez que actuamos en la vida
estamos modificando nuestra relación
con el otro, con el entorno
con nuestra familia
con esos amigos que cambiaban
de conversación cuando nos veían.
Cuando entendemos esto, realmente estamos
viendo qué importancia tiene
ese paso atrás de Velázquez,
que yo aquí hoy, quería reivindicar
por esa mirada ajedrecística,
esa mirada del pintor.
Todo este tipo de reflexiones:
pieza movida, pieza tocada;
pieza tocada, pieza movida;
esta responsabilidad que tenemos
en el juego del tablero,
cobró todo el sentido práctico,
no solo el retórico o filosófico,
cuando me invitaron el 8 de marzo de 2016
a dar una conferencia
en una cárcel de mujeres en México,
en el estado de Morelos,
el Cefereso número 16.
Me puse de 200 reclusas
y les hice ver y subrayé la importancia
que tiene esta reflexión.
No sabéis, de verdad, cuando subrayé
una máxima que para los ajedrecistas
es fundamental, y es que
una sola mala jugada
te hace perder la partida.
Da igual cuántas buenas hayas hecho antes.
Las 200...
(Aplausos)
Las 200 reclusas de ese Cefereso asentían
como habéis hecho vosotros.
Y yo estoy seguro de que cada una de ellas
estaba rebobinando cuál fue ese error
que de momento les hizo perder la partida.
Lo bueno de todo esto es que nos quedan
muchas batallas todavía, muchos juegos.
Seguro que tenéis tableros de ajedrez
en casa escondidos.
Vamos a sacarlos,
vamos a desempolvarlos, vamos a jugar,
vamos a conocer mucho de nosotros,
de nuestros hijos, de con quién juguemos.
No hace falta mucho: diez
o quince minutos os van a ser suficientes
para entender las reglas básicas.
Acordaos del ejemplo de Magdalena y María.
No existe edad, no existe condición.
Cualquiera podemos disfrutar de él.
Y tengamos siempre presente
que nuestra mejor jugada,
que nuestro mejor... quiero decir
nuestra mejor toma de decisiones,
pero me estaba acordando de las presas,
pero sí, ¿por qué no?,
nuestra mejor toma de decisiones,
en este tablero ajedrezado,
que es la vida, aún está,
porque podamos hacerla.
Muchas gracias y buena partida.
(Aplausos)